what's the justification for raising the
numbers
for the semis and the final at wembley
well good morning and thank you for
inviting me um i mean i think to some
extent it is the benefit
of our success with the vaccination
program we have been proceeding
cautiously i was
lucky enough to be at wembley last night
where obviously there was a
smaller number permitted that was part
of our
events research program and we're now
moving to the next stage
where for a number of events we will
increase the capacity
but at every stage we're obviously
listening to the scientific advice and
we won't do anything
that will put public health at risk and
even though the capacity is going up
people will still be required to
demonstrate that they've either had
two vaccinations or that they've had a
negative uh coveted test
yeah but away from fifa officials being
allowed into the country quarantine
free and they will be at wembley the
world health organization is saying
they're quite anxious about the whole
idea
well we have listened very carefully to
our own scientific advisors they are
content that we can move to this next
stage
yes there will be some people coming in
but they will be coming in
to attend the game they'll be under the
strict
restrictions as to uh what else they can
do
and we have measured these things very
carefully
and we won't do anything that we will
put our success at risk
but as i say i think we are now at the
stage where we can look forward to
some relaxation if this pilot uh works
then hopefully we can expand it
into course i want to talk about that if
i may the events
results programme as it's called erp for
the benefit of my viewers
um so far there's been a series of of
mass event trials including
the fa cup final at wembley of course
the brits the snooker world
championships
what are the findings of that report
well the initial findings were very
encouraging
and we we're going to be publishing the
full analysis
before we take the next step which
hopefully we will be able to do
in july and we've said that we will make
that report public
but it's a complicated exercise it needs
a lot of an
analysis and obviously we want to be
absolutely confident of the findings
before we publish
why is it complicated either lots of
people didn't get covered as a result of
going to these events or they did
well obviously that's that that's the
headline but you do actually need to
look and see you know whether or not
there was transmission
the age groups how how it appeared that
it was spread
you know these are technical and
complicated
events which are to test
the success we have had of containing
the virus and to make sure that
as we move to relax further we're not
going to put that at risk
and i think that people would expect us
to carry out a very thorough analysis
we've always made plain that we will
publish and we will publish before we
announce the next steps
yeah but this has been going on for ages
hasn't it mr whittingtail and she knew
who was there because they were
checked quite thoroughly before they
went to these events you knew what age
groups they were you knew whether
uh subsequently they had coveted or not
because they were tested
um why can't given that it was
successful
why can't things like theaters and other
events open up now
lord lord weber says apparently the
report has recommended opening theaters
well i can completely understand why
lord lloyd webber would like to see
theaters
we would all like to see theaters
reopened but we are proceeding
cautiously
we have selected a small number of
events as part of the
events results program and you know we
are now looking at those findings and if
they are positive then i very much hope
uh that we will be able to move to step
four it has been delayed because
obviously
uh there was an increase in the numbers
particularly of the new delta
variant but we are extremely hopeful
that uh
come july the 19th we will be able to
move step four and
everybody will be able to go back to the
theater hanya you were going to say the
delta variant so i looked up the figures
125 reported deaths uh the
week ending the 11th of june the lowest
in eight months and certainly that does
take into account
uh the delta variance so again i put it
to you
the nightclub industry at the theater
industry
so the festival industry is on its knees
they need to see this report
you have it and you won't show it to
them
we will share it to them we've said we
will publish the report we've always
been clear
we will publish the report before we
move to step four we will demonstrate to
people
the evidence and the analysis of the
results of the programme
and the basis on which we have reached a
conclusion that it is i very much hope
safe to move to step four and you know
we have been through
a horrendous year or more now um the
last thing we want to do is throw away
the success we've had
it's only another couple of weeks the
chancellor has provided
okay okay okay uh okay we've got it
we've got it
19th of july you're going to publish the
report before then yeah
yes we've said we will publish it before
we reach decision on step four okay fine
uh talk to me about holiday uh
destinations uh where are where are we
as far as that is concerned looking at
the figures
our figures in the uk are much worse
than most of mainland europe and uh
malta um are we expecting several
european countries to go onto the green
list later on in the week
well we've said that we will be looking
later in the week
to make revisions to the green list and
i hope that we can put more countries
onto it you know i quite understand why
people
want to go on their summer holidays i
would say to them that you can have a
great whole day in britain and i think a
very large number of
people will decide this year that that's
what they will do
but having said that people you know
like to get away to the sun
and there are a number of countries on
the green list i hope that it will be
possible to
increase that number but um that's
something which we will be looking at
as i say later in the week okay i'm just
looking at the figures as we're chatting
and uh malta has got one in a hundred
thousand
poland three and a hundred thousand
germany
eight in a hundred thousand italy twelve
and a hundred
thousand france twenty four and a
hundred thousand our latest figures were
ninety three point seven
in a hundred thousand here in the uk
what on earth is the justification
for not having european countries on the
green list
well that is just one of the measures
that you have to look at
there are of course others we are way
ahead of any other country in europe in
terms of the proportion
of our population that are vaccinated
and that offers a degree of protection
and as we've seen
these figures can change quite quickly
you know we were sadly
uh forced to put portugal temporarily
back onto the amber list because of the
uh case rate there so you know the these
are expert decisions by the scientists
they make recommendations to government
and it takes account of a range of
factors
um okay well i'm sure you understand and
appreciate the frustration of the travel
industry lots of them are demonstrating
later on today they're also
planning to sue you you can understand
their frustration can't you
of course i can understand their
frustration not just of people
whose business is the holiday industry
but also
i know millions of people who you know
want to get away
and i very much hope that you know we
will soon be at a position where
that we will begin to return to
normality
i think international travel is going to
continue to be perhaps one of the more
challenging
areas in terms of resuming normal life
but we are all working towards that
nobody wants to force people to say in
this country or
wants people not to be able to go to the
theater again
and we are moving in the right direction
um are you confident
that if people want to go overseas costa
del sol
or wherever this summer that they will
be able to
i'm certainly hopeful um that is
something which you know we are keeping
under constant review
as i say i hope very much that it will
be possible to put more countries
onto the green list i hope that it may
even be possible in due course
to relax or itself restrictions for
people who for instance have had two
vaccinations but i mean these are things
which you know are being kept under a
constant examination
and when we feel it is safe to make
those changes
then we will do so yeah of course we've
been able to do that for uefa and fifa
officials haven't we coming to the
football
david davis has called that morally
inconsistent
well we've always said that for you know
some people who are uh important
to players for instance we've heard
specifically
no no of course not but we're talking
you know we're talking a very limited
number of people
who are coming in and they're also
subject still to uh quite significant
restrictions
they're not just able to come in and
travel around britain and they come in
to attend
a match and then go away again and
you know we we wouldn't have been able
to host
the tournament at wembley if we hadn't
allowed the players and people
associated with the teams to come in to
do so
you are aligning allowing chanting at
matches um uh particularly at wembley
but seven people can't sing hymns
together inside
well i mean i you know we have said that
professional cars can now sing
people amateur choirs can sing outside
um
but you know as i say we are proceeding
cautiously i would i very much
understand that you know amateurs
um are very popular a lot of people
enjoy singing i quite enjoy singing
and i hope but we'll get to the point
where you know people can resume those
kinds of activities
but you know i think most people
watching this will feel but the
government is right
to proceed cautiously and do nothing to
put at risk
the huge success that we have had in
terms of beating this forest
trust me you wouldn't want to hear me
singing mr whittingdale a quick question
about channel 4
before i let you go to what question is
the answer
privatize channel 4.
well there has been a huge
transformation in the way in which
people
watch tv with a lot of new entrants
which is fantastic news for the viewer
you now have a choice between
you know sky and netflix and amazon and
apple as well as the traditional public
service broadcasters
channel 4 has a very special place
amongst the broadcasters
it has been hugely successful but with
that kind of competition coming on in
order to sustain it over the long term
we think it will need investment it only
capital to invest in programming
and it is subject to really quite strict
limitations
whilst it is in public ownership so we
have said that it's the right time to
think about
you know a future model for the
ownership of channel 4 which will make
sure that it continues to go on
providing that very distinctive content
uh and serving the public service remit
which it has
uh way into the future why would you
want to get rid of it when it's it's had
its best financial year
last year ever
well we don't want to get rid of it we
want to sustain it this is about making
sure that it has a long-term future
in a very different world to the one
which most people are familiar with
[Music]
we are looking at the ownership
possibilities one of the
requirements i think over the coming
years is that channel 4 needs to have
access to the kind of capital investment
it is you know in order to retain
viewers you do need investment in good
content um and with some of the new
entrants netflix and amazon they are
spending huge amounts more
than channel 4 is able to do and an
alternative ownership model may make it
uh possible for them to
access the kind of money to continue to
provide great programming
okay i'm being told that you have to go
just want to ask you very quickly how
was the football last night you were at
the stadium weren't you
i was i there are some benefits of being
a dcms minister
um obviously it was a great result i was
delighted that england won
um you know i'm looking forward i don't
think i probably could manage to get
there again but i should certainly be
watching
uh the match next week and hopefully
we'll go all the way